a subcommittee work session for House
Bill 264 uh I call to
order um
the the piece of information we
circulated is for some background
information as to what is gone on in in
the United States as far as current
status of similar bills and similar
actions so I wanted to make sure you had
a copy of that information uh just to
get us all up to speed okay thank you
thank you madam chair
so Madam chair for
me yes I understand that this is dealing
more with the process than the approval
in other words it's dealing with how you
get to modify the birth certificate not
trying to say we can do
it that's correct
currently um individuals can get their
birth record changed it requires uh them
to go to court have to have the same
medical information the same document
that that a physician would sign but to
uh but to also um set up a court date
and speak to uh a judge who'd make a
decision whether or not to change it
um I I have found out from some other
some transgender people who have gone to
court and some of the justices in New
Hampshire essentially rubber stamp their
request they don't ask any questions it
comes across the desk and it has a form
from a physician and they just stamp it
and send it along which surprised me
because in the past I have heard of a
number of Physicians that require
in-depth information and sometimes the
presence of the the signing
physician that seems to be very high
burden to make the physician have to
come to
court yes uh as well as um costly
because the applicant also has to pay
for the physician's
time um uh I was also uh I although I
changed my information in Massachusetts
my physician had to sign my form that I
brought down there and notorized it the
physician charged me for their time to
go get the documents notorized so it was
7 $ for their time that's an interesting
comment because if I understand what you
said and how this supplies
here the
governing body over the birth
record is predicated upon where the
birth occurred what I'm trying to get to
if I was born in New Hampshire and I'm
in California now I have to go buy the
regulations of New Hampshire because
that's where my birth record is however
if I'm in New Hampshire as a resident
today and I was born in California I'm
subjected to the rules in California not
New Hampshire is that correct that's
correct thank
you cuz I was I was asked to add
something to U this this bill to allow
people from out of state to change their
birth record in another state and uh in
uh investigating that that would have
been an
legal uh activity um if I just focused
that essent
uh the the process that we currently
have in place and how could we improve
it for one time for individuals to
change their information um which is
similar to all of our surrounding states
and to many that are listed on on um the
summary that we've got um it would just
be one step the second time any wants to
change the information they would have
to go and discuss this
with um a Justice in the court
system um can I ask a question of where
birth certificates are required and for
what
purposes if you know that um I the
background on that sort of is um I
actually have an LSR in around suspended
licenses because driver's licenses were
initially intended just for driving but
they've turned into a deao form of
identif ification so that means that if
somebody has surrenders their license
after a suspension they have to get a
non- driver's ID but then that has
implications that they move out of state
because then they're not flagged as a
driver and there's so many other
consequences of using a government
document beyond what it was initially
intended for that I I think we find
ourselves trying to deal with that creep
we have our social security numbers that
were intended just for for making sure
that we were able to track contributions
but now they're essentially our ID
number our driver's licenses are our
main form of
identification and it seems like our
birth certificates that should be a
historic document of how we were at
Birth now we're being used in so many
other ways that it it seems like kind of
a creep of documents being used for more
than they probably should
be thank you thank you for that question
um as as I I found out well when I got
my birth certificate changed I brought
my my that information to the Social
Security office they didn't require the
birth certificate what they required was
the court issued document with my name
change and um and that's proved valuable
because um the IRS tracks that
information and um does take a look at
the individual's name as recorded with
their social security
number okay on the the
passports um you need to provide
initially you need to provide a birth
certificate and you can you can
self-identify what your gender is so
whatever information is changed on a
birth certificate and a birth
certificate at the time that has changed
currently
um if you have a court document that
says this is my name change as well as
the document that the physician says
identifies your gender you can get all
of that information changed at one
time um so if they they have just the
doc the document from The Physician that
says there's a gender change but there's
no name change the name stays the same
but the gender can change
so when I went to get my birth record
changed I had the court ordered name
change document at the same time so both
were changed at at one time thank you
that's incredibly helpful I know that's
sort of a scope another uh scope creep
when you're using the passport for
Internal Documentation but that one is
based on your identity and who you are
and how you identify right and I think
that that actually is is a great way to
be able to show who who you are now yeah
who you have become and who you are
going forward that's correct and in my
case everything was changed on the same
date um in Newton Massachusetts the my
original birth record still
exists um and the the it identifies that
was changed um there um and the document
that was issued uh issued in
Massachusetts didn't include any
information about my name change or um
birth record information changed on the
document they issued okay and sorry as a
a clarification that was the document
the new document that you received from
Massachusetts with your new updated
birth certificate didn't annotate that
there had been a change that's correct
okay right now here in New
Hampshire if someone someone goes
through the process of getting a court
ordered um
G or court court ordered modification of
their birth record um if they if they
update that along with the name the same
time there is no marginal note if they
do it separately there is a marginal
note about their name
change okay thank you that's absolutely
helpful
yeah but looking through this if I read
it correctly L and I'm always subject to
reading things
incorrectly if I look at the original
birth certificate it does get
retained the original birth certificate
is retained by the city clerk the
original birth record is U retained by
the
um our Vital Records Office Vital
Records Vital Records by the state of
New Hampshire not the city clerk right
okay they don't keep they don't keep
those records local to the town it's all
in the Vital Records Office but the
original is always available the
original will still be maintained we
don't it's never lost okay that's
correct thank you I I think my my main
opposition to this is that it's a birth
record and not a Now record the idea of
having a passport be a Now record is one
of those wonderful things where it can
show who you are now but our birth
certificates are listed as birth
certificates um do you know if there's a
I don't think that there's a process so
that if um there's a baby and
biologically the father is gone from
possibly that first night of conception
or da of conception or later on and then
there's a father who has stepped in and
truly is the one who lives as the father
and is the one who has raised them
possibly from birth or before there's no
way to change a birth record to update
that that would simply be adopting them
even though their true lived reality is
is that that other man is the one who
truly is their father as opposed to
Simply the donor that's understood but
the uh yeah that that person would still
be listed as an adopted parent okay so
following on that
logic if a mother at the time of birth
on the birth record does not identify a
father so it's going to come across as
only the recognition of the mother but
no father but subsequent to that if the
father decides to step forward and take
responsibility can they go back and
modify the birp rec to include the
father's name on the
record and um with that is that done
through genetic testing or just an
attestation that they are in fact the
father you know I don't know I don't
think we do genetic testing now for the
father to begin with so well paternity
tests we do I we have some information
from
research that some of it's rolled into
like child support but across the
country um there are
specific in statute or in rules that
allow a correction for
certific either to be removed
they
so that sort of I think helps me
understand and what I'm trying to get to
is the birth record at the time of birth
is not cast in stone it could actually
be modified for different reasons
depends on state depends on State and um
and then as clarification but it may be
updated but it is for what is true at
the time of birth that because you're
establishing them through a paternity
test was that a correct understanding
that there's a paternity test in most
places that do
this
okay
and
then but there
are
thank you thank
you soorry and I'm not trying to be
argumentative or diminish the experience
of anybody that's going through it it's
just looking at it reading through this
I was thinking about how important it is
to make sure that people aren't having
to present a document that's traumatic
to them um and to make sure that they're
able to show who they are as they are
living but the idea of a birth
certificate when it's not the conditions
that were at Birth is one of those
things that feels like it's a changing
of language because it's not a living
certificate it is a birth certificate so
philosophically I have that issue and I
hear what you're saying about it being
living versus again something that's
cast in stone and that's what I'm trying
to get to with the researcher it sounds
like it is a living document because you
can go back and make changes to that
document if you can make changes to the
document therefore becomes in my opinion
a living document and that's what I'm
trying to get to with the father if the
father is going to be changed and we
allow for that to happen then we do
allow for the modification if we do
allow for modifications to the record in
essence it becomes living document um
and and thank you for that but if that
is is based on genetics and genetic
proof that they are the genetic father
um that updating it to reflect the the
genetic conditions at the time um I
think would be is different than being
able to reflect that person that adopted
them even as a as a three-month-old
fetus I I I don't disagree I think the
argument I'm trying to make is that if
we allow for any modification to a
document it's becomes a living document
and I think that's probably more point a
disagreement there but we know how to
disagree in a friendly way so that's
good that's one of the things I like
about this committee and Like About You
in
particular and I will say the same to
representative Leon I do enjoy the
ability to have a hearty healthy
discussion and at the same time still go
out and have lunch absolutely I think
the scope of that what this bill says is
whatever the current situation is listed
on the birth birth certificate as far as
parents go that's what's used uh if that
information changes on the original
birth certificate or even
the what whatever in place the original
as well as current would be listed on
that document as of any any changes
because that would be the information
required um but if it's been changed
it's it's sort of a succession of things
if it's been changed um and then like
say the the real father is added um that
would be an additional piece that's
available for information but the gender
information would have changed in the in
the time period thank you do you know
how inex birs are handled on I it seems
like from what I understand it seems
like a best guess which really really
really is harmful to interex individuals
what the way understand it is that an
intersex child when they're born
um um there is a notation made on that
record that um that still needs to be
determined and I think there's a few
months time I'm not sure if it's I it's
not years if I understand that correctly
um and part of that is to allow some
development time to figure out whe it's
whether one gender is specific or not um
and that is it's a challenge for for uh
interex people uh as they grow grow up
um as as their bodies may change however
I know interex people who uh would like
to get their gender changed and will
have to do something similar in this
process to get that changed and that's
that would this would actually help them
in that process because they can get a
statement from the position that says
this is the gender they identify
as
Madam chair if I may to the
researcher what I see under type of
process it says administrative court
ordered but it also talks about type of
certificate it says amended new can you
help me understand what's the difference
between amended and
new
whatever
that they might just draw a line through
the old one or put a notation in the
side saying this
Chang so you would see that there was a
change on the amended one but they
won't thank
you so if I understand
that what this Bill does is it still
remain amended or are you looking to
make it a new because this issue of the
process to get there but at the end of
the process are we looking for a new
certificate or an amended certificate it
it's issued as a new certificate okay um
but the original is the original is
noted that it has been amended correct
because I think one of the things I
during the testimony was the fact that
in the state of New Hampshire the
process itself
is somewhat flawed it's a process of
where to get the form who has the form
where to go to B record so that's
dealing with the process itself so
that's what the spill's trying to clear
up clarify or to make more understood
easily understood in the process itself
to be easier but at the end of The
Journey we still going to have a new
certificate versus amended one so I want
I'll break it apart into two parts one's
the process document you're handed
currently is you you have a new document
there's no notations okay thank
you um thank you I'm looking at the New
Hampshire information from the 50 states
um comparison there's six months for
changes or corrections to the birth
record without approval of the registar
with using a form so um well six months
will give some time for parents of
interex children to help figure out so
that they're not just randomly assigning
birth a gender at Birth um I I
definitely understand that that process
can be longer and ongoing I've uh had
the pleasure of knowing a few interex
individuals in my life and they are one
the ones I've known are wonderful
wonderful unique people that are dealing
with a path that not many of us have to
walk that's
correct this this bill does not
address non-binary
people um a bill was introduced I
introduced a bill over four years ago
that was passed in the House and Senate
and went to the governor's desk and he
did not he he vetoed it um primarily
because it included
non-binary um there are more States now
that have included that um but we still
have the same governor and I I know that
we have a number of uh uh transgender
people that I identify don't identify as
non-binary and this would be important
to that group of
people so I brought it forward as you
see
today now if if the classification of
non-binary is something we need to
consider for the future that's the
future um I believe that there's only 13
states that currently issue uh a
non-binary
identification so I I do want to say
Madam chair that the way that you wrote
this and the way that you addressed it
is a very clear and elegant way to deal
with some of that uncertainty over how
the court process is handled and the
idea of having the court order for
return is sort of a disincentive for
anybody who wants to be a bad actor
because they exist amongst every group
of people if you find me a group of
people that doesn't have B Bad actors in
it I will amazed yes so um I I just want
to say that that that that that's not
about any any particular group other
than the fact that we're all humans and
that is why I I decided it was best when
we wrote this up that it did
require any additional changes would cry
approval from u a legislated
official
yeah Ian I guess the way that I stand on
this is that that if you believe that
birth records are something that doesn't
reflect birth but reflects who you are
now that this is a very good way to go
about it but I would like to see a
return to birth records being about
birth and separating out our now records
into a different category and
classification and for that reason um
I'm not going to be able to support the
bill just because I think that we should
get back to more clarity on what
document does what not because uh of any
intent to deny people the ability to
truly be who they are but simply because
simply because I think that I just need
to stick to that foundational
principle understood I can appreciate
your concern there Madam chair if I may
yeah if we go back to first of all I
want to say this isn't quite the
research I want to commend the
researcher for all the work that's put
into this if you go back and look on
page 30 4
of what she
provided and if you look under page 34
you'll see in the leftand column New
Hampshire if you go down to
V5 it does in fact allow for a new birth
certificate so the end result is not
going to change it's just the process
we're going to use to get there
thank you I recognize that so hear your
foundational principle I don't disagree
with you but I think that issue has been
dealt with here in the statute so
therefore the statute currently allows
for that fundamental or foundational
document to be changed all we're talking
about here is the process to get there
thank you and I also want to thank the
researcher for the amazingly thorough
job of doing this this is phenomenal um
I recognize that that's the way that our
laws are currently um I would actually
if we can figure out a process I'd love
to figure out how we can point more
things to a Now record when you're
trying to identify how a person is and
how they are to be treated today as
opposed to the birth record and I'd
support any efforts to do that I just I
just don't want to move along a process
when I think that we need to move away
from birth records as anything other
than a record of birth understood so and
I appreciate all the work that's gone
into this I expect that I'll be in the
minority with this position but it's one
of those where I want to just hold true
to what a document is and just stop the
scope creep let's reflect who we are
with something other than a birth
certificate and make it so adults aren't
really handing in birth certificates
willy-nilly because we know we know
you're here we know you exist and we
know that who you are today may be very
very different than how you started off
and that we need to respect and
appreciate those individuals and that we
need to do that in a way where we're not
tying it to a historic type
document thank you I
I believe some of what Society has
changed in the the mechanisms that we
use information it's probably why
organizations don't require a birth
certificate for instance our our U DMV
does not require a birth record and the
um getting a passport Now does not
require a birth record uh especially to
change things you can and and in both
those situations you can self attest as
to what is your gender you don't have to
have a document from a physician so well
thank you and with that I think that
it's important to have the birth records
to be able to establish citizenship
because there's a difference between
citizenship and not uh but beyond
documenting that you as an individual
were in fact born in the United States
for the purpose of citizenship I don't
really see much value in the birth
certificate going forward other than
establishing that citizenship correct I
I
agree it's interesting you talk about a
living document versus a non-living
document I'm trying to go through and
identify any document out there that is
truly not a living document in some
capacity I'd say a death certificate
it's not and I'm not making a play on
words there but once it's been ruled by
the medical examiner how you died it's
it I believe is almost impossible
without a significant evidence to change
it but it can be changed and sometimes
it comes down to the medical examiner
will put down the cause of death and
then later on change it based upon other
evidence and change the reason for the
death so I'm trying to get to is every
document we have in some capacity has
the flexibility to change that document
somewhere along its Journey um thank you
and with that you are with those Chang
is you're better reflecting the
conditions upon that time of death as
opposed to any subsequent events just as
um our laws allow for a name change for
those who are living but other than an
infant who dies very very soon it
doesn't allow for any of those changes
for somebody who is now deceased because
once you're deceased it pretty much puts
a stop on that and as a birth record if
we can close that narrow that window to
say that the birth is pretty much for
the fact that you were born here and
beyond that we need to look to other
documents to show who you are
today
correct however if you go back and look
at page
34 in the first six months you can
change the birth
record without any court order without
any so we do allow for a record to be
modified within its first 6 months so
therefore if it can be modified in 6
months what's that's on that's my
argument and you're very very wonderful
at mincing words and fighting fighting
specific Avenues and I appreciate that
very very much um I think that that
flexibility is very necessary because
otherwise if you had no opportunity to
change that you'd have parents coerced
into um immediate surgery on their
babies when they're born interx and the
idea of pressuring a parent into making
that decision immediately before they
get to know their child get to know the
process understand the consequences of
those choices I think would be far more
harmful than holding that window open
for six months especially because our
birth record process is one that's that
is undergoing some improvements because
our birth worksheet has some that needs
to be attested to under penalty of law
because that's what goes into the birth
record and then others that are quite
intrusive that perhaps you you shouldn't
be held to answering those truthfully
under the threat of law when they're
social questions and and personal
questions that have no bearing on the
legal status of your
child
however when you look at that six months
back to the original comment I made
earlier about the father it does allow
for the mother or the father step
forward without a paternity test to be
added to that birth record it does allow
for incorrection on that birth record
from
being one gender versus the other gender
which is a mistake to correct the
mistakes so it's not just the unisex
it's a question of that time the record
itself is not something at the time of
Birth cast in
Stone thank you then I guess perhaps we
shouldn't call it a birth certificate we
should call a fourth and fifth trimester
certificate I I I I love getting into
these points with you representative
Merchant I absolutely do but I I I think
that as far as this goes I agree that if
this is a process we want to proceed in
this is a very well- written bill but I
I'm just sticking to my philosophic
point that that about the birth
records okay very
good times lunch any any any add
additional
comments no I want to say that I totally
understand re Leon um in the issue that
she raised in her philosophical beliefs
um we are definitely a different sides
of the belief on that part of it but I
do understand where you're coming from I
have a lot of respect for where you're
coming from and at this point in time
what you said before is what the statute
is today is what it is and if I
understood correctly is that the way the
statute is today you'd like to see a
fundamental change in the statute itself
which not what we're going to today um
to clarify that I think our our I guess
if you're talking talking about the
living document versus a record of the
birth or the first six months of life
that would be a fundamental difference
um I think that any changes to the law
would have to come long after the birth
certificate no longer is used for any of
these procedures that needs to be a
shift that happens culturally and that
needs to happen by recognizing other
documents and refer letting the law
reference other documents as opposed to
the verse certificate when you're trying
to establish the condition of the person
now and they they a true identity now
and until that happens there's
absolutely no reason to do any sort of
harm to anybody on changing what these
birth certificates are even if in the
future there's some idea that all we're
doing is a simple snapshot at Birth uh
that would be starting at that point as
far as I'm concerned and we have a lot
of societal shifts that need to happen
to recognize that that the people's true
lived reality can be very different from
how they were born um before we can get
to changing any of those details and I
think that as Society ships that way to
recognize that it almost becomes a
relevant um around that part of the
birth certificate because if we are no
longer using a birth certificate to
prove who we are when we're 43 or 57 or
89 or even 18 that it no longer no
longer carries that consequence and it
would be a very very different document
yes so do we have a birth record in a
birth
certificate I think I think I think we
just need to move away from the birth
certificate as a form of identification
uh for anything other than
citizenship I I I think we're I think
we're discussing something that probably
goes much further than than what's being
proposed this is mental gymnastics
between myself and repres probably a
societal change um and how we how we
view things um and what's required and I
think some of that is occurring Now with
uh where
organizations legal organizations are
not
requiring the same thing that we
required 20 years ago Madam chair I'll
make a motion
to approve the bill as written and
recommendation to the committee to be
utop passed as
written
thank you um I'll I guess I will second
that correct you can second that as the
chair
yes um and would like uh I guess I'm
looking for a vote from from both of
you my vote is to vote in the
affirmative okay uh my vote is to vote
in the negative simply because I I think
that we should move towards the separate
recognition of who you are sorry it's
not supposed to be discussion in voting
mode I apologize m yeah okay and and my
vote will be in the positive to bring
this forward so we have pass vote that's
a two to one vote two to one two to one
vote Yes to be recorded that sounds
wonderful where should we go to
lunch so uh with that uh I will call
this this meeting uh
closed okay thank you thank you madam
chair
for